віце-президент США джо байден по передавши
україну про ринок зняття санкцій з
росії за права дружини хід диску з
конфлікту на донбасі танк цю криму
процесинговий друк виступала заради
закордонних справа нью-йорку
піймав ми знаємо вже всі українці задути
виправить то зараз є інший
миші 5 гривень і адже кивали сказати ну
чому ви ти санкції проти Москви
економічні санкції євросоюзу про ту
росії був і супровід плитка 2014
євросоюз відразу на пиріг у подібну
моя жінка порталі всім краї нам квітів
подібні до віце-президента США за відома в
годину майданчик щура winsett три дні 2 3
роки на розбавляю по телефону з
українською корениться вам укладена поліл
авеша проводите реформи а так вже
продавлю слухайте не франції-то італії і
dns косого ти санкції за його байдена
продумала на доступній дні відразу
старче з петром порошенком про кулуари
засідання генеральної асамблеї оон у
нью-йорку коли український лідер
від remo в критих не гарантії wedge а
обсі вам один мільярд доларів
узами на фінансове харчування ринку заходу
україна обіцяла реформи
алла прогресу явно за мало найбільшою
катувати завищується до реформи системи
правосуддя байдена гадів так вже про
до єдності до німецьких у ось дивної
до пост цієї ситуації
калли в їхньому провалі схвилювати
україну джо байден виду маяк добрий друг
україни віце-президент одержаних штатив
часто проїжджаючи так і його і на
одноразове заявляв про Петренка
українців проте змій на його тональності
це важливо сигнал для української влади та
лом з на крок від і гвинтівок одягнені і наша
чи над нинішніх ви ікла в с брик вважаю
щури біженців україна може витрачають і
Петро їм до заходу